[Music]
what's up it's Samuel leaves here and
this week winners on the Wednesday we
have the new and improved version of
Samuel Leeds hi dude you're killing it
bro Thanks so this is Nathan winch
Nathan you have done how many deals I've
done about eight deal eight property
deals mixture of deals yeah me no money
down and how did you get all the
knowledge to do all these deals so
essentially was just from watching your
videos really so I didn't really do any
of the costs or anything
exactly so over those over the past sort
of four months I've done those deals
just from watching the YouTube videos
and then I kind of then took it stage
further and died so cool so you you've
done what at what tell me you've
packaged and sold some deals well how
much did you make last week last week
three and a half grand last week how
about the week before put me on the spot
all the week before at about 13 and a
half thirteen and a half thousand pounds
in a week high five or fist bump fist
bumps and Lease Option agreements yeah
how many of those have you done I've
done four of those so you've done for
Lease Option agreements what is a lease
option agreement
so it's essentially where you kind of
take on a property the the owners can't
really sell they've got limited options
you know there might be negative equity
or something like that so you kind of
offer to pay their mortgage in the bills
and everything take on the repairs and
then you can let it out as though it's
your property so you can benefit benefit
from the cash flow and the capital
appreciation because of course they can
offer you all the perks for buying a
house without putting any money down
when he's out just legals buy now pay
later yeah essentially and you did that
from what your watching my youtube
videos watching youtube videos
dude that's impressive that's impressive
and then you hunted me down because you
wanted to give me money yeah yeah you're
like dude I've got all these houses I
made three year off grand this week all
right
13 grand last week I did it from
watching YouTube I need to give this
dude some money kind of yeah kind of
yeah
you're now join the Academy I have the N
last two weeks and you've not even done
the crash course no I did the
peterborough one oh yeah I just did it
that's the first one I that's first
cross Scott so you did the crash course
a few days ago and how was that was
absolutely insane it really intense
really engaged
you wish that you've done the crash call
sooner I did I do actually I wish I'd
done that first cuz it's kind of like a
taste for everything yeah yeah kind of
don't things a little bit backwards but
it works I know you're on the Academy
now I'll shoot it in that a long time
ago but I'm glad that you hunting me
down I always say if you become
successful from reading my books or
watching my videos or telling the crash
course please hunt me down because your
success is my oxygen and the fact that
you have I really appreciate that I
really I really honor you for that and
looking at the figures I know we've gone
over your figures and I know Alistair's
sat with you and stuff I mean we've
looked into what you've done you're
killing it I just thought why not have
your own winners on a Wednesday because
it'd be such an inspiration because
people watching this at home might be
thinking literally what where our
people's excuses like date they have
their input they're watching the same
videos you were watching and you've done
this we have no money so why don't you
just tell us a little bit about sort of
your story why did you start how did you
even find my videos on YouTube so it was
I think was a friend of mine that told
me about you and I didn't think much of
it and then I kind of came across one of
your videos on YouTube and I started
watching and I thought wow this is this
is great because it's a little bit about
my background just absolutely Matt so
yeah i i I've kind of always been an
entrepreneurial type so being sort of
self-employed since like the age of
twenty twenty-one run a small medical
business working with the NHS and then
sort of sold that in Matthew was March
2017 Oh a couple of properties didn't
really know what I was doing and had
those for a while and then sort of in
the past five months four or five months
been watching your videos realize I've
done everything wrong
you know not making a great return on
those properties or anything and then
started implementing from literally the
the YouTube video so lease option thing
like that and then realize that well you
can make a much better return and kind
of refine that's one of the buy-to-let
and you know did some interesting stuff
so you bought so you did some stuff in
business
you bought how many properties before
you started watching my channel too so
you bought two by two layer properties
yeah
but you're saying they were quite bad
probably yeah when I run the numbers
based on the ROI we know how to work out
now they've quite low yes so you've
bought the properties you I know you
bought like a nice car and stuff like
that yeah then you watch my youtube
videos about four months ago
man I've got it all wrong yeah so then
you refinanced the properties yeah and
then you thought I'm going to start over
but then the weird thing is the property
deals that you've been doing recently
they haven't even involved any of your
money I've they know so you've still got
money that ready to invest so that money
separates us and and I think that's
really that's really interesting because
even if you've got money you you still
want to try and do the best saw deal you
can do you don't want to spend money if
you don't need to so yeah so I've just
been doing sort of lease options really
actively for the past few months and
that does have worked really well you
know and that's that just the lease
options alone have made me financially
free so that's what we through if you
don't mind yeah the figures of the lease
options because I find it really
interested in it's the same was a guy
who came on the show called Ian
Patterson yeah yeah money you know his
story I know him yeah yeah you know it
how do you go in so I watched I think it
was the very first winners on Wednesday
watched his videos when I went to
property networking event where he was
giving a talk and literally just to just
to sit down with the guy and pick his
brains really took him out for a for a
couch and he's fabulous he's absolutely
killing it so I didn't even know that
yeah it's a small world yeah but then it
is if you're in the right places like I
don't you know yeah so so in Paterson
same sort of thing there was an NDA in
patents he was working corporate job he
had money but he chose to do lease
option agreement cuz his in his mind
he's thinking why would I use my money
when I don't have to if I think my house
for free I'm not gonna buy a house and
pay money for it necessarily so that's
what that's really cool what did you
learn from him I think to try and do
chunks of deals all in one because I
think he does hold portfolios and lease
options yeah he does now and it's the
same effort doing a portfolio he's
trying to do one so you you know you may
as well try and go for the bigger ticket
items but yeah learnt learnt a lot from
the guys and he's quiet he's quite
reserved as well and he's but he's
really shrewd businessperson he's
fantastic he's also an omni on the
academy now same as you though he came
to the crash course he just from the
crash course he went on and all these
deals made all the money he's now got
like a 2.8 million portfolios yeah I've
read that yeah off the back of the crash
course his story made all newspapers and
stuff after he came on winners Wednesday
which yours probably well as well who
knows and then he was like dude can I
join your Academy I'm like he can but
why
you know so same going story yeah so
yeah very recently so that's incredible
so okay so you just you watched his his
story you watch some of my other videos
about lease option agreements why don't
you just tell anyone that's watching
this thinking what on earth is a lease
option agreement what what is a lease
option agreement yet so essentially a
lease option agreement is a it's a way
of acquiring a property now we're paying
for it later
yeah so you kind of take over all the
other nasty bits that the landlord
doesn't want because normally Sloane
also don't want to be a landlord other
accidental or it's something to do with
probe a or whatever or they're in
negative equity and you kind of take it
on pay for on bills the mortgage
everything else and then but you can
rent it out and keep the returns and
obviously because there's sort of like a
restriction on the sale to just you you
know you benefit from the caps
appreciation as well because basically
you pay the owner or the landlord enough
to wash its face for them exact so
they're not making money from it each
month but they're not losing money if
that's a mortgage or whatever it is you
pay them a small amount which is
negotiable and then anything more than
that that the property rents out for is
yours exact to keep yeah but then also
you have a option to buy that property
usually within or after so many years
how long do you run your lease options
for they're about ten years Wow so I had
plenty of times you'll be an old man by
then exactly so you when your what your
twenty eight so when you're 38 you'll
have the option to buy them at a set
price but we all know what happens the
house is over time we do they go up they
go up yeah and especially over a 10-year
period yeah so the chances are that they
might even be double the value in which
in which case you'll have y'all have
made so much money in capital
depreciation and you're also financially
free from the cash flow just from it's
got to be the best strategy I think it
is I think it is especially for those
that don't have a lot of money or bad
credit or whatever it's fantastic and
we've got people that are literally you
know we've had an illegal immigrant to
come and doing Lease Option agreements
it's incredible how you can buy a house
that way with no credit I mean I'm not
I'm not endorsing it
what I'm saying is regardless of your
situation it's incredible what you can
do when you have the power of option
absolutely yeah so where did you fight
did you do was your first lease option
was it one-in-four or did you heard that
it were they've they've all been
individual so I don't Wow yeah so it's
just sending out hundreds of letters
buying details from Land Registry they
you know they all send a colored
envelope type thing so basically all the
stuff and my youtube channel yeah yeah
yeah yeah but I did one of the lease
option I did buy from a saucer so
there's that option as well but yeah
usually deal sources aren't selling
because you not them don't you if you
find them you keep if you found a free
house you ain't selling it unless unless
usually it's got something wrong with it
you know so okay so so you've done for
all individually you found them on your
own part from the one but you've done
for but I by following the strategies
sending letters basically you just put
yourself out there right yeah and talk
to people yeah okay so give us give us
an example of like the most latest lease
option agreement that you did give us
the figures I think it was a for betting
New Castle yeah the the option to buy is
a hundred thousand
I think the mortgage that pay on there I
got the the seller to change to an
interest only mortgages well there we go
very home so I let me just explain that
yeah so the seller was on a repayment
mortgage but it will be it'll be more
simple what why did you why did you
change it to interest down watch it for
cash flow so so that was really the only
payment I'd have to make because it was
a single letter so the mortgage is
really the only payment I make so how
much possible so it's I think it's about
98 pounds a month so ninety a pound them
up to the mortgage for bed HMO how much
are you renting now for well it's not
hate you like to say it's a single dad
or family but it's 450 months okay so
you're making a few in Japan on that and
then the others if you add them all up
together how much cash flow are you
making so I don't know the lease
officers on their own but all all the
properties together it's about three
three thousand pounds a month and I
think the net on that is about seventeen
eighteen hundred months that's great
yeah that's great so 1719 Japan a month
that is your average salary exactly yeah
that is like your average salary so
you're now making your average salary in
passive income on top of that you're
sourcing properties and passing them on
you made 13 grand in a day
yeah in a day in a day that was at this
let me just say this is the difference
you before brought you will do in
YouTube videos and you were doing really
well but you then came on one of our
advanced trainings I did yeah how was
that that was fantastic so that was the
one day deal selling master class with
wireless stuff and that's when things
blew up that's where things blew up and
I thought the more I do these things the
more I get involved the more successful
I am so I kind of famished did you make
after going on that probe was it was it
was it was it a direct result of that
program when you made your 13 direct
result of that program yeah so we were
given like a little booklet and now yeah
yeah I implemented the booklet yes after
as it said yeah and the guest that was
it I think it was I became compliant on
the Friday and did that deal on the
Monday yeah so it took quite a while to
become compliant and then sent the deals
out to the list and they sold in about
four or five hours of Sun and the 13,000
pound that's in your back right now that
that is yeah and that's so I think the
terms of expired and that's that's mine
yeah your money man yeah that's
incredible bro high-five that is so cool
and and that I think that's the power
the thing is when you invest in yourself
yeah you will always see a return mmm
like oh yeah you can you can invest in
property and make your 20% or a 50%
return but that money that you invested
in yourself you've probably already made
100% return probably more what you have
yeah that's incredible but but I think
credible so what would you advise
yourself if you were talking to the 12
month younger version of yourself what
would you say education I think
education yeah getting to get into some
education you know whether it's paid on
whatever you know read some books read
more books watch your YouTube videos
yeah of course and just yeah just teach
yourself because although I was already
kind of in property I was doing it all
wrong and the returns were abysmal I
could you know I'd probably need like
hundreds of those sounds to be
financially free think about so so yeah
a little bit of Education and yeah
you've got to teach yourself because it
is the most important investment I
thought I just totally believed that
what would you have thought four months
ago when you first started watching me
on youtube if you don't own that fast
forward four months you'd be sat here
with me
Wednesday completely financially free
able to make 13,000 pounds in a day what
would you thought I'd have said mmm no
that's I would have been a bit skeptical
yeah and a bit skeptical yeah well how
can you make that money you know if you
if you starting with not a lot and you
know but it's possible yes well that's
so great yeah so what are your next
steps I want to double the property
portfolio by the end of the year well
yeah it's not a massive goal I mean it's
doable very well you're on the Academy
now so I'm only Academy now hold that
you can pretty much you should helps do
that John the Academy yeah so don't hold
me to that but it's it's it's great so
yes so to get more property whether
that's a lease option or whatever it
doesn't have to be do more deals I think
I'm averaging one to two deals a week so
I think the overall income including the
including the the properties is about
ten thousand a month something like that
so which is massive from just four
months ago you know I've only just
joined the Academy as well so you know
expecting big things yeah yeah okay
that's so good
talk to me Nathan about mindset because
you know it sounds so easy you could
watch this interview you could think oh
that's easy he just bought a house for
no money in yeah isn't it but so many
people fail so most people that watch my
youtube channel you're in the top 1% you
you know not only have you taken the
action and invest it in yourself which
most people won't do yeah but you've
also sent the letter has made the calls
there must have been down days there
must have been days when you thought am
I wasting my time here there must have
been times when people told you you
stupid like no yes yes yeah absolutely
yeah I mean it's as with anything in
life isn't it when you try and kind of
aim higher people try and pull you down
you know you've got to
I think mindset is 90% of it actually
and 10% of it actually doing the deals
and knowing this stuff I think the
mindset is incredibly important but like
Sam I've always been sort of an
implementer and I'm you know if I decide
I want to do something I'm gonna do it
so so yeah that's hell but yeah no I
agree I think mindset it probably the
most important thing that you've got to
have first and then education put the
two together and you know good things
happen and the advantage of when you
started is that number one you've been
successful in business so you've you've
got that business mindset yeah you know
and you understand what makes a good
deal number two although you'd bought a
couple of properties and they were
good houses you were you understood the
process I think that's what maybe one of
the reasons why you've skyrocketed so
fast not to give anybody else an excuse
but I mean geez
13 grand yeah oh yeah that's the start
after training bang yeah II know
anything about sourcing you know so
until I started really I didn't even
know anything about lease options I
thought they were only for commercial
property and they were watching your
videos and I thought why am I doing this
I'm and then you know get start writing
the letters start sending them out yeah
it's a noisy background have you got
like everything you touch turns to gold
like well I hope so yeah but it's just
I'm just an implementer of you know take
risks and I go out there and tell
everybody what I'm doing and yeah and
that sort of thing and you know say yes
now and worry about what to do later I
think most of all say now that's the
real stuff that you know yeah you could
talk about these options but the real
people could understand these options
all day long but unless there this stuff
yeah
prepared to take action prepared to take
a risk you know prepared to look so
prepared to say I'm a property investor
when you haven't actually got any
properties that on the basis that you
speaking it out because you know it will
happen to be prepared to spend money on
programs to invest in yourself in faith
that it will pay off because you know
that you're gonna implement exactly one
I mean then that's the stuff that makes
you successful yeah cos it's the stuff
like what tell me about the crash course
what did you learn
I'll tell you some in that alone which
was really interesting was the the way
you find the postcode of the property so
when you were on Rightmove yeah I don't
know the post-college property and you
click on this sort of a broad all right
the whole the whole training cost was
worth just that one thing saved me so
much time there
insane yeah no it's just the whole thing
was brilliant it was really intense but
I guess it's a test to see because you
kept is there to like 11:00 at night
like genuinely 14-hour day 14-hour day
two of them it was brilliant but yeah I
think that's that's you but you've got
to be willing to do that to make these
deals happen okay so you've got yeah
that's every day yeah but for someone
doing this so but it goes fast I imagine
it goes fast yeah because you're engaged
and you're up and you've you've got a
you know jumping up and down and it's
brilliant yes it's fantastic
yes
and sometimes people say you know 14
hours what people have got remember is
it's not 14 hours me on stage because a
lot of the day you're doing stuff you're
making phone calls oh yeah in line
you're on Rightmove you know you're
doing stuff so no that's really cool
okay what advice would you give to
someone watching this who was maybe
young guy in their 20s or whatever or
anyone but just someone that's really
hungry they haven't got a lot of money
to start with what were the best steps
for them to take right now as a result
of this read a book and just do it do it
you know get your get your hands dirty
and get in there I mean like I said
before sort of saying yes and worrying
about it later
yeah I've got my hands burn a few times
but you know I'm now able to just take
the day off to come here whenever I want
you know that's not gonna affect me what
I've been you've been the most
influential books that have helped you
yourself by low rent high pressure and
then I read I read Simon's at she's book
yeah property magic great book great
book fun and it's a great guy oh yes
yeah he's brilliant yeah yeah and just
watching the YouTube videos I guess so
yeah I think your passion and energy is
really you know it's ripped off a little
bit because yeah you know you've you've
got it you've got to be active haven't
you yeah and want to do it 100 percent
100 percent that's so cool well listen I
really appreciate you coming on the show
problem I hope to see you kill it I'm
gonna be holding you to a can no you
will if you don't do many more lease
option agreements in the next few months
you're gonna be punched in the mouth so
now you're gonna do so you're gonna be
so successful and I'm so glad that you
join the Academy and again thank you for
hunting me down thank you for putting
faith in yourself but also in that
training and I'm glad to see there's
paint off yeah thanks so thanks Nate
Cheers my name is Samuel Leeds thank you
for watching winners on a Wednesday
every single week we interview a success
students for your inspiration you can
watch more right here on the playlist as
a whole playlist of them but what you'll
notice is every single winner on a
Wednesday always starts with them coming
to my two day crash course so if you
would like to be a winner on a Wednesday
literally come on my crash course and
who knows in three months time you could
be here in my offices on this show as a
winner on a Wednesday so get yourself
booked on the crash course watch more
have fun I'll see you next week